les français en ont ils assez de gilets
jaunes en croire une certaine presse
la réponse est oui s'appuyant sur un
sondage ifop le quotidien le parisien ne
craint pas d'affirmer sur twitter le 12
septembre que seuls 10 % des français
déclarent encore soutenir les gilets
jaunes dans l'article mentionné
expliquant que le mouvement s'essouffle
on apprend un scoop
une étude ifop que nous dévoilons en
exclusivité révèle que seul un français
sur dix se sont proches du mouvement
un constat bien fâcheux pour le retour
des contestataires du pouvoir dans la
rue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le sondage en question n'est que
mentionné dans l'article en ligne et
n'est pas accessible
aussitôt bfm leur emboîtent le pas voilà
ce qu'affirme l'article d'après l'étude
seuls 10% de la population âgée de 18
ans et plus se sentir et proche des
gilet jaune soit entre 4 et 4,5 millions
de personnes
l'adresse du lien elle ne laisse aucune
place au doute alors les gilet jaune
serait-il isolé mal-aimé fermez le ban
étonnant pour un mouvement encore
soutenue en mai dernier par 53% des
français
toujours selon l'ifop alors comment
expliquer ce désamour les français
aurait-il attrapé le virus du
néolibéralisme durant l'été
[Applaudissements]
aurait-il changé de couleur préférée et
bien non et pour comprendre ces titres
il suffit de se livrer à la lecture
objective d'un sondage pourtant très
claire les journalistes du service
tchèque news de libération ont donc
jouer au chevalier blanc en examinant
les termes et les chiffres de l' enquête
le sondage avait posé la question diriez
vous que vous êtes un gilet jaune les
femmes 10 % sont en réalité les
interroger qui avait dit se sentir gilet
jaune mais oh
que voit-on 41% de plus ont déclaré
soutenir le mouvement
la calculatrice est formel 10 + 41
cela fait cinquante et un pour cent de
soutien des gilet jaune ce qui veut dire
que seuls 49% ne les soutiennent pas
sondages à l'appui une courte majorité
est donc toujours favorable gilet jaune
apparemment l'école en visio semble déjà
avoir laissé pas mal de séquelles en
maths et cette nouvelle bévue ne va pas
arranger les rapports entre les jets les
jaunes et les médias traditionnels